Transcriber: Reem Mohamed
المدقّق: Arwa Mohamed
كم في اعتقادكم عدد الأشخاص الذين تخرجوا من
علوم الحاسب الآلي في العشر سنوات الأخيرة؟
عشرة آلاف شخص، عشرين ألف شخص،
حسنًا مائة ألف شخص؟
في الحقيقة إنه حتى ليس
رقمًا قريبًا من هذا.
يوجد مليون شخص تخرج من علوم الحاسب الآلي
في العشر سنوات الأخيرة  فقط،
و هذا ليس من العالم بأكمله،
بل من أمريكا فقط.
هل تستطيعون تخيل الرقم؟
بالتأكيد  معظمكم  قد  سمع عن
ما يُدعى بالذكاء الاصطناعي
أو Artificial Intelligence أو AI من قبل.
و هذا ما يعمل عليه معظم شباب الحاسب الآلي.
لمن لا يعرف AI فهو في النهاية بعض الآلات،
التي تحاول تقليد الذكاء البشري،
سواء عن طريق التفكير مثلنا
أو التعبير مثلنا.
سأقولها بطريقة أخرى،
تخيلوا أن AI مخ مبسط للإنسان.
هذا المخ يبدأ بتجميع كم هائل من المعلومات؛
حتى يقوم عن طريقها ببناء تفكيره،
التي بها يعطينا النتيجة، التي نريدها.
و بالطبع كلما زادت هذه المعلومات
كلما زادت كفاءة النتيجة.
هل يعني هذا أن AI سيتمرد علينا و سيقوم
بتدميرنا مثلما يقول جميع الناس؟
لا AI لن يتمرد بعد.
يقول العلماء على AI الآن narrow أو محدود،
حسنا لماذا؟
و هذا لأنه لا يستطيع القيام
إلا بمهمة واحدة فقط.
والمشكلة الأكبر أيضًا،
أنه لا يستطيع فهم المهمة التي يقوم بها.
اقصد إذا  كان فاهم، لكنا قلنا
حسنًا إنه فاهم، لكنه حتى لا يفهم.
تخيلوا أننا لدينا شخصين، يونج و أحمد.
يونج لا يفهم إلا اللغة الصينية،
وأحمد لا يفهم إلا اللغة العربية.
أراد يونج أن يبعث رسائل إلي أحمد
باللغة الصينية و هو يعتقد أنه سيفهمها.
بالطبع حينما استلم أحمد الرسالة، قال
ما هذا أنا لا أفهم شيئًا.
قام بالبحث بعض الوقت
حتى وجد كتابًا به كل القوانين،
التي تسمح له الترجمة إلي اللغة الصينية.
بدأ أحمد باستخدام هذا الكتاب بأن يقوم
بتكوين ردود و بعثها مره أخرى إلي يونج،
و عندما استلم يونج الرد قال
أن أحمد  يفهم  اللغة الصينية بشكل تام.
ونحن نعلم بالطبع،
أن أحمد لا يفهم اللغة الصينية،
فهو فقط اتبع بعض القوانين،
حتى يقوم بتكوين الرد.
أحمد هذا هو بالضبط Narrow AI.
حتى إذا شعرنا أنه فاهم
فهو قام بإتباع  بعض القوانين فقط ،
حتى يظهر أنه فاهم و جيد و هكذا.
ياه، هل هذا يعني أن AI المنتشر حاليًا،
الذي يقول عليه العلماء أنه narrow
أو محدود،  فاشل ليس له أية قيمة.
بالعكس هو قوي ..قوي جدًا، وحتى
تتعرفوا على قوته ،
سأعطيكم بعض الأمثلة  على
AI موجود حاليًا،
أول مثال معنا هو Optimus Bot،
الذي قام  ايلون ماسك بصنعه.
حسنًا ماذا يفعل هذا الروبوت؟
هذا الروبوت الرائع يستطيع التعامل
مع المواقف الجديدة و الصعبة في لحظات،
ومن خلال هذه المواقف الجديد يتعلم
و يطور من نفسه أيضًا.
هو قريب جدًا من الطفل،
أقصد على سبيل المثال،
إذا أريته النار و كم هي تحرق
يعود بسرعة إلي قاعدة البيانات الخاصة به
ويخزن بها هذه المعلومة المهمة؛
لأنه عندما يرى النار مرة أخرى،
يبتعد عنها سريعًا دون أن يقول له أي أحد.
لكن طبعًا إذا أعطيته مهمة صعبة
لم يتعرض لها من قبل،
مثلاً أن يفهم لغة لم يرها من قبل،
لن يستطيع فعل أي شيء، فهو محدود جدًا.
لكن في الحقيقة يوجد AI آخر بأسم Chat GPT
و هذا قدم له أي شيء له
علاقة باللغة و سيساعدك.
أسأله فقط أي سؤال،
بأي لغة و سيقوم بدور Narrow AI و سيبحث
في القوانين والمعلومات التي لديه،
و سيعود إليك بإجابة مناسبة جدًا لسؤالك.
في الحقيقة القوانين الخاصة ب Chat GPT
عبارة عن معلومات لانهائية من الانترنت.
أقصد مثلاً إذا سألته،
Write me a short ted talk about AI،
سيظهر لي هذا.
كما ترون بدأ Chat GPT بعمل سكريبت
كاملة من إنتاج و بودي و كونكلوجن و كل شيء
فى أقل من نصف دقيقة.
الاسكريبت، التي استغرقت مني شهرين
تم إنجازها أمام عيناي في أقل من نصف دقيقة.
رائع للغاية، صحيح؟
بالطبع ستحتار كيف أنه ينتج هذا الكلام،
هل لديه مخ يفكر به أم ماذا؟
في الحقيقة كل الذي يقوم به
Chat GPT أنه يبدأ
بأخذ كام كلمة من سؤالك،
بعد ذلك يعود مرة أخرى إلى
القوانين و المعلومات،
التي يمتلكها،
حتى يحاول توقع بعض الكلمات التي تليها.
حسنا ماذا يلي توقعه لهم؟
يعود مرة أخرى لقوانينه و معلوماته
و يتوقع وهكذا،
لهذا تجدوا دائمًا Chat GPT يرسل
الردود الخاصة به متقطعة،
لم تكن أبدًا على بعضها.
و أيضًا مثال آخر على AI محدود جدًا،
هو STM Kargu.
STM Kargu هو Military Drone تستطيع فهم
المنطقة المحيطة بها دون مساعدة أي أحد .
من سنتين في عام ألفين واحد و عشرين
قامت الأمم المتحدة بعمل تقرير؛
لأن STM Kargu برمجوا أنهم يحددوا
التارجت من خلال مستشعرات كثيرة و
برامج معقدة ويضربوه بدون أي تدخل بشري .
لكنها محدودة جدًا لمهمة التحديد والتسديد،
و مثل أي Narrow AI لن يستطع العمل
لأبعد ما هو متبرمج عليه.
هل يمكن لمثل هذا الشيء ان يطلب لك برجر؟
نفس الكلام هل يمكن ل Chat GPT
أن يصنع لك محشي؟
بالتأكيد لا.
وهل يمكن ل Optimus Bot أن يسيطر
على العالم كما يقول الجميع؟
بالتأكيد هذه الأشياء المحدودة ليست
هي من تشكل خطر كبير على العالم.
و لهذا فقد توصل العلماء إلي
مصطلح خطير جدًا.
يمكن أن نصل إليه في أقل من عشرين عام،
هذا المصطلح هو General AI.
تخيلوا أن Optimus Bot بذكائه الحاد و
Chat GPT بمعلوماته اللانهائية و
STM Kargu بتنفيذه الدقيق
تجمعوا لتشكيل AI فريد من نوعه،
و ليس هذا فقط بل أيضًا  يستطيع فهم
ما يقوم به.
ليس مثل AI ،Narrow AI المرعب
هو General AI،
هذا المدمر يستطيع تعليم نفسه و
يستطيع فعل أي شيء أنت تقوم به.
و أيضًا يستطيع استخدام معلوماته و طاقته
في اكثر من مهمة و موقف.
General AI ذكي جدًا و لكنه
في الوقت نفسه خطير جدًا.
هذا يعني أن General AI إما أن يقوم بتحسين
البشرية و جعل حياتنا أفضل بمراحل،
أو يدمر البشرية ويجعل حياتنا أسوأ بمراحل.
فهو لديه القوة، التي يستطيع بها تدميرنا،
لكنه في نفس الوقت
لديه القوة، التي يقوم بها بتحسيننا.
القوة التي سيستخدمها ستعتمد على
كيفية إستخدامنا نحن له
و ستعتمد أيضًا على تعليمه
الأهداف والقوانين المهمة.
ما زال لدينا القدرة على
البرمجة و التطوير و التحكم في AI.
ما يزال بإمكاننا برمجته،
لمنعه من برمجتنا.
دعنا نستخدم AI؛ لتحسين حياتنا،
دعنا نستخدمه لتحسين خبراتنا و حل مشاكلنا.
تذكر أن المستقبل ما زال في يديك،
لا تتركه.
و مع الذكاء الاصطناعي
الإمكانيات لانهائية.
شكرًا.